es la primera vez que svetlana tica no
pesca ya habla con la prensa desde vilna
la capital lituana desde que se exilió
el pasado 11 de agosto la líder
opositora bielorrusa pidió a los
ciudadanos que continúen en las calles
chichas violarlos belarús despertó
cientos de miles de personas salieron a
las calles de ciudades y pueblos para
decirle al gobierno ya basta
ujaldón basta de mentiras de intimidar a
la gente de violar las leyes y de
violencia la violencia debería parar los
presos políticos deberían ser liberados
y se deberían celebrar elecciones libres
honestas y transparentes price book in
exile ya la opositora respondió así a la
posibilidad de que rusia apoyó al
presidente alexander lukashenko con
soldados golfo llamó a todas las
naciones a respetar la soberanía de
nuestro país y a respetar la elección de
nuestro pueblo de choice of agua tipo
las declaraciones se presentan el mismo
día en que fueron interrogados dos
integrantes del recién creado consejo
coordinador opositor al que las
autoridades acusan de querer tomar el
poder más real esto respondimos que el
consejo coordinador no tiene el objetivo
de intentar hacerse con el poder el
consejo coordinador es más un servicio
mediador para resolver un conflicto para
resolver una disputa pacíficamente hay
una situación compleja ahora entre las
autoridades del estado y el pueblo
bielorruso
por su parte el presidente alexander
lukashenko aseguró por primera vez que
eeuu se encuentra detrás de las
multitudinarias protestas ciudadanas y
acusó a la unión europea de seguirle el
juego debido a que el bloque decidió no
reconocer los resultados de las
elecciones del 9 de agosto